[Musique]
amiral le tampa bay a été porté disparu
au large de la péninsule de kola
monsieur on a perdu 1 2 sous marins
j'ai ordonné à la 6ème flotte d'envoyer
une équipe de secours nous ordonne de
traversée des mers qu'aucun sous marin
américain n'a encore jamais traversé
immergé l'appareil
nous assistons au déploiement militaire
russe le plus agressif de son histoire
on a surveillé le président russe et son
ministre de la défense du rof
c'est un coup d'état
un franc tireur qui importe du mini
cécillon libérer le président à karine
credo on sauve le président russe on a
des yeux et des oreilles au sol
avoir mon commentaire avec ap de nos
gars on va récupérer un président russe
lui nie pas cette mission
le rec troisième guerre mondiale
vous avez un cinglé sur le dos lancé
un bon dieu on vient de déclencher une
guerre non elle avait déjà commencé
j'ai risquer la vie de mes hommes
j'ai risqué mon avis
de combat notre avenir est en jeu
avant tout par et pour encore